tada
here we are everybody's here yeah
scooped over into the frame a little bit
you're over there
we'll move this far move this thing over
uh this doesn't go anymore okay well
hold on
okay let's tell you yeah
see you're fine it's just maybe i'm so
[ __ ] big that i go out of the screen
see
[Laughter]
yeah you're so full of crap
i think it's because you were like
leaning over there right that's why
because it looked like your face was
like half of that thanks here i just
i'm just sitting down now hey everybody
all right looks like everybody's here
maniacs here badgers here leaving cheese
see what they're talking about sandra
changed her name to sandra german peanut
butter ambassador
okay yeah yeah okay
cheese here oh my god that's awesome
yeah
in that last uh uh video that we posted
was on death
with on death proof um
a couple of people including t said they
went and they they saw omega man
and said i was right about it omega man
is a [ __ ] badass flick
and uh i responded to you guys comments
in there with t
and everything i sent the lyrics to a
song about
omega man and i am legends by white
zombie it's called [ __ ] i am legend
because of course it is yeah it's a
[ __ ] it describes that to the tone
and everything about burning this [ __ ]
clean and
got a holy gun come loaded to kill
everything that i am and just
you know he's like mega man he's talking
about his dick i can't believe you know
that he cannot believe it
it's all gone away you know it's it's a
[ __ ] bad song and he's just running
around killing [ __ ]
and they're just like him they're
monsters just like him yeah
it's it's it's a good song i don't
really i don't remember it like i like
white zombie but i don't think i
remember that
i'd probably remember it if i heard it
starts off with kind of a mellow intro
which kind of i didn't i don't really
like the intro that much it's about a
minute and then it just goes into it you
know yeah
you know
like it does yeah cannot believe it you
know what kind of [ __ ] yeah
all right yeah that's that's fair enough
running around burning [ __ ] up
with gasoline and shooting stuff putting
out fires with gasoline
no he was [ __ ] burnt that's that
david he was he was shining the body
whatever that means i don't know if it's
the body of his car or [ __ ] shot into
shining the dead bodies that he was with
gasoline you know the dead bodies of the
vampires that he was killing
that's one of those phrases that like it
sounds kind of cool but then when you
think about you're like wait what that
doesn't mean anything
no like i said i just imagined somebody
with um
you know like skin kind of glowing like
a metropolis and they're just like
waxing it we just pour the
gasoline burn this [ __ ] clean shine
the body yeah
[ __ ] you know so it's shiny because
it's on fire i guess so we're just
burning everything off of it making
fire's not shiny
making it smooth have you ever seen
anybody set themselves on fire
yeah that's not even just not in person
and it pops off and [ __ ] falls on the
ground and it's dead in there
yeah like a barbecue and they like
smooth yeah it looks smooth for a second
that's probably he's talking about
sandra said does anyone watch stephen
king's the stand the new version
i've totally forgotten about it wanted
to see it already months ago you know
what i
i remember hearing about it like a while
back and then i kind of forgot about it
too
huh man there sure is a lot of like
stephen king [ __ ] out i was i was
looking the other day because i was
looking on amazon like for
another book that i was ordering and i
didn't realize
how many books steven [ __ ] king has
released
since the last one that i've read i'm
like [ __ ] i can't keep up
with all of this stuff knocked off he
said he was gonna retire
and even like that was like [ __ ] man
that was like 15 or something years ago
and even then he said yeah after this
book i'm gonna retire i'm like shut up
no you're not
and he didn't he can't stop it's a
compulsion
i you know i get that t said that omega
man needs to need to be remade
it's a little dated but it's still great
for 71.
i wouldn't change the story hardly at
all i would just update
the practical effects and everything you
know what i mean with all the car wrecks
and running people over and
it would i just leave that [ __ ] just
practical effects
very little cg make it kind of like mad
max
real elemental he doesn't talk much to
it
i don't think they could do it today not
in today's hollywood it'd have to be
like a really good
decent budget independent film that's
how that's the only way you could do it
because it didn't have that many people
in the movie you know
the cast isn't big and they probably
wouldn't like the message today
but it still holds up man that that that
message
britney says my daughter is in fourth
grade she got told her story for school
was too scary and she should write about
happier stuff she can write about scary
stuff when she's older
yeah that's about the age i started
reading horror though it's not that
weird it's not that weird
and i you know i was drawing monsters
and [ __ ] like that when i was a little
kid too and i turned out okay
i got i got complained that too and i
got sent to the guidance counselor a few
times
but you know like i said i turned out
all right it's fine it's fine yeah
all right i'm busting out ciggies early
because it's wednesday oh yeah
so amanda's here yeah i sent you a
message about that
shirt because i remembered you saying in
the chat that you hadn't got a shirt for
a long time and i was like oh that's
weird and then today we got one back
man how many did we sent that like
months ago
it must have been sitting in a dead
letter office somewhere because that was
like the last one
when did we send out the the shirts with
the grim reaper design on it that was
[ __ ] ages ago right
a couple months ago at least yeah and
that and it only just now came back
today
and i was just like what the [ __ ] and uh
yeah so also
so i got your new address i got the
message so i'll send you that one and
then we're gonna do new shirts too uh
i got i went and uh got the
transparencies for the new shirts
printed today
so we will probably make the screens
tomorrow and friday and maybe we can
start printing them this weekend that
would be good
no need for me to said that was quicker
on the draw tom's quick on the drop but
i'm not i don't really get the reference
bro you're gonna have to clarify a
little bit
something to do with practical effects
baby yeah i think that's why because he
said something like they should do with
practical because well i kind of feel
like they should do most things with
practical effects and like i said i'm
not one of those crotchety like
[ __ ] it's all like oh they
should never use cgi or anything i mean
obviously it's just a tool like anything
else
um but you know it if your whole movie
is cgi then why are you just making an
animated movie
omega man has to be all practical
effects because it has to look very
gritty
and there's nothing out of the ordinary
it's a dude fighting a bunch of
mutants yeah it really shouldn't need to
be
no need for that [ __ ] wrecking his car
and busting open
garages and trying to mess with
[ __ ] security systems that he had
there's no reason for any kind of
practical effect
yeah he says i am legend would have been
better with practical in my humble
opinion well yeah i
i agree with that it would have been
better with practical effects it would
have been better if the monsters talked
like they did in the book and that he
was actually the last man
and if they hadn't [ __ ] up the ending
and be like will smith saves the world
or
however much it was and i was just kind
of like lame that's not what the book is
like and that like negates the whole
point of that they named it after the
book which none of the other
adaptations did yeah and then they made
the
ending like not even like the [ __ ]
point of the title fight yeah
it will make you so mad will smith will
smith saving the saving the earth
is not the meaning of omega man
because neville he was a scientist
and a soldier he created the damn virus
that got out
and killed everybody he was a creator
and a destroyer
he was god and the devil he was the
monster and the savior depending on how
you looked at it like shiva
yeah exactly god of creation and
destruction neville wasn't
good he was insane but he did
save the planet he he was part good and
part evil
and it goes back uh uh um [ __ ]
cheston or charlton has now called him
chest chest and loved that role because
it showed man
as killer ape and that's you know it
goes back to his thing with the
planet the planet of the apes yeah yeah
you have art and science and medical
technology
and then there's bio warfare and
soldiers and fire
and and ignorance and religion and
everything that's
it man is a killer ape and that that's
that's the meaning of the movie
sorry somebody was talking about scones
with clotted cream or scones
if you wanted to those are [ __ ]
delicious i even had some of those
virgin uh used to have
way back in the day when you could fly i
don't know if you can still fly direct
from orlando to
gatwick airport anymore but you used to
be able to it's like an overnight flight
they had two of them a day
and that's the one i always used to take
over there and they used to have
really nice it was kind of expensive but
they had really nice food like even in
the cheap seats in the back
and for breakfast they would always
bring you scones with clotted cream and
strawberry jam and they were
pretty [ __ ] good i mean for airplane
food i'm not complaining and i had some
when i was over there too like in some
uh
little restaurants and stuff but man
those are so [ __ ] good yeah the weird
thing about it though is that even
though
a lot of when i was in the uk like a lot
of the food is kind of fattening like it
is in the in the u.s
but i found myself like losing weight
while i was over there like without even
trying to
even though i felt like i was eating
chips like every day maybe because i
was walking everywhere i didn't have a
car over there and there was a train so
i just either just walked or took a
train everywhere so maybe that's why i
don't know
but it just i was like oh i'm getting
thinner like even though i'm eating all
this super fattening food
how does that work and i think and the
portions were smaller too
no i needed ashtray here i have
yeah i can smoke these because there's
no nicotine in these yeah i got a couple
more packs of those i'm just finishing
up this pack that i bought at the bar
the other day
i haven't smoked it forever i won't
touch cigarettes but this is just
you can smoke one and then you don't get
a craving for another one really
yeah that's pretty good you just get
yeah well that's what i figured they had
like good reviews and stuff and i was
like
maybe i'll try that out just because
when i drink i like to have a sticker
right yeah kind of like vaping
and i can't vape anymore it makes me
cough too much
vaping kind of lost its i'll tell you
what man it got me to stop smoking
cigarettes
it did immediately yeah immediately
didn't pick one up which i didn't think
that would happen
and um you kind of you um
you actually stopped vaping a little bit
before me yeah but i eventually like
stopped doing it too
more with vaping yeah and it in a way
it's like it's cheaper than smoking for
sure
but we i mean for a while you got super
into
vaping and you were making all yours you
know if you remember like some of our
old shows where he wrapped
yeah he made her his own coils he made
his own juices and he made all that
other kind of stuff so we had all kind
of gear i got sick of carrying it around
it is kind of a [ __ ] i mean they do
they have much littler ones nowadays
because
because our friend jen has one yeah that
she brings out
and it's really small it's like it's
probably about the size of
this maybe like a little bit bigger it's
just like a lighter so it's not like a
big deal now if you guys hear the
doorbell i'm waiting on delivery so
oh okay well you know yeah
yeah i got i think i got the last ship
for my
uh halfway to halloween costume today
i got the dress i got the hair i'm doing
bride of frankenstein because i figured
i had to buy the least [ __ ]
to do that because i can do that with my
own hair i can just tease my own hair up
but i needed i had got some white spray
so i could spray the stripes
and i got a dress i didn't want to get
because i i dressed up as bride of
frankenstein a long time ago like
probably in the early 2000s because
where i used to work
uh they had a halloween party every year
and everybody like you know went all out
and they dressed up and came
into work and i did one back then and i
did a more
accurate uh thing where it was just kind
of like bandages and then it was like a
white shift dress over it and that looks
kind of cool but i was just like well
i don't really want to spend money on a
white shift dress because i'm never
going to wear that [ __ ]
so i got a dress that's white but it's
kind of like it's
gothy looking you know what i mean and
it has kind of like
strings and [ __ ] and then i have some
white tights and maybe i could put
bandages over it and i have some like
big clunky like black shoes that are
kind of like frankenstein shoes
yeah so that's what i'm gonna wear yeah
t
said that the practical effects would be
good better make up for the
for the zombies not really zombies the
vampire the
the what they call them the family
yeah family or like it was still like
the source family that was still pretty
good for
for 71 when i was a kid it was it was
pretty shocking when i took those
glasses off
and they had those contact lenses in
there i was like wow
because those are hard to get back then
now you can get them off the internet
nothing
well and back in the old days too i
think i don't know when they made the
transition but back in the old days if
you see some horror movies from back
then and you see like you know
christopher lee like with the red eyes
and stuff
those uh contact lenses were glass and
you could only wear them and they were
thick and you could only wear them for
like a couple minutes at a time before
your eyes just started streaming
another thing that tripped me out
watching that as a kid is that when
richie the little black
kid when he turned remember that he he
was turning
and then they flipped him back and then
he says i can talk the family you know
we can we can all be together and he
goes back to city hall where they all
were
and they tried to he tried to talk him
out of being what they were and to take
the damn
the blood treatment that neville came up
with yeah
and you don't know what happened then
neville goes down to rescue him and they
find him [ __ ] hanging from they
crucified him yeah and that was a kid
and in the 70s in the
american movies you weren't supposed to
be killing kids yeah they did that in
europe they're like whatever kill the
kids
[ __ ] but american movies yeah they're
like don't kill the kids and i
must have saw this around 74 75 probably
when i saw that movies
maybe 76 so i was you know maybe seven
years old
but a little younger than than richie i
guess
but uh i saw that scene and i was like
oh
man they killed the kid yeah you're like
oh man these [ __ ] are bad
yeah and they're in there and they're
like we're all satanic and they're down
in city hall and
making sense and it's kind of like the
it's kind of like the inquisition
and they're you know talking about
mankind and his evil and his wheels and
his machines and
you and your woman it must be destroyed
and you know you're a thing of the past
and
[ __ ] was [ __ ] it was heavy man tila
is talking about it another good costume
would be uh the vampire from let's scare
jessica to death
yeah that actually would be good nobody
would know who you were but that's
that's never stopped me before
um i also love that movie so tila you
have really really good horror movie
taste
yeah so yeah so one of the things i want
to get to say something
what's that the best vampire i've seen
best vampire outfit i've seen recently
was the stragoi from [ __ ] blood
vessels well yeah that looked kick-ass
yeah well and like and he spoke romanian
and [ __ ]
and i can kind of understand it because
portuguese romanian real close to us
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
and when his subtitles came up it was
all in that damn gothic [ __ ]
lettering
i loved that
[Laughter]
i love that they made the subtitles yeah
and you know how a vampire works but you
don't know if you don't know what a
stragoi
is you're like [ __ ] what is this
thing you know and
the the rules for a stragoi was the
original the vampire was a ripoff
that's the only vampire yes they could
have sex with the dead and breed with
them
think of that so you could have
and then you could have living vampires
and dead vampires and then undead
vampires and then there were dead bodies
involved in this [ __ ]
so you might have a vampire dad and your
mom might have been a corpse and then
you come out as a living damn
half dead vampire it's it's all just
kind of blur
you're probably gonna need some therapy
at some point yeah what the hell is
something
going on i feel like that's an under
rate like an underappreciated
kind of thing which is which i think was
why i liked blood vessels so much
because i'm like now see
vampires are really played but that's an
angle that not a lot of movies do
so i really did appreciate that actually
yeah and then like when they showed the
stragoi
dad when they show the hit the hiss
sarcophagus
and the carvings on the side it made all
kind you're like what the [ __ ] is that
man but it made sense when you know what
a stragoi is yeah
him standing in there and all the
[ __ ] dead bodies reaching towards it
and it's like
king of the dead and king of the undead
and then it was also a sorcerer
you're like is it a psychic what the
[ __ ] is no it's a goddamn sorcerer it's
a witch
magic powers it's a witch yeah yeah it
has like all the best [ __ ]
yeah vamp from a vampire and a witch
like yeah and also a little bit of a
werewolf too and a zombie
zombie yeah depending on how you were
born depending on who your parents were
sure yeah i mean that's pretty rad yeah
tila is asking favorite vampire movies
and i was gonna say oh easy the hunger
and then i see that mango kind of beat
me to it best female vampire of all time
is catherine de novo yeah i agree with
that
i love that movie i still got a soft
spot for interviewing the vampire
i do as well and and i'm going back i'll
pull an anne rice on this
like i said when i first heard that tom
cruise was going to be in it i was like
nah man come on
come on yeah t brings that black yeah
blackie let's scream black you'll scream
we're both good
i love both they need to be remade i
love that well i love
i think i like this sec they're both
good but i think i like the second one
slightly better because it has that
voodoo angle which like i said they
don't make enough
old-school like haitian voodoo movies
you know
a lot of people might might scoff at
this but i really liked um
eddie murphy's vampire movie vampire in
brooklyn i liked it that actually held
up really well i remember
i have it on blu-ray i remember not
loving it when i first saw it but we
wanted
it again like i was like oh that was
much better than i remembered
i liked it when it came out i saw the
theater um
i liked it too but i didn't love it i
kind of forgot about it and then i
ordered it on blu-ray watch it again
it's great
it's great yeah it it's true to
to vampire lore it's um it's hard to
beat blacula but it's
it's it's right in there you you can
tell that that eddie murphy had seen the
blacula movies
yeah you know you know he saw this so
it's right there
i liked it it sure much it was a lot
better than coming to america too
which wasn't terrible that wasn't
terrible it's just that it was pg
that needed to be it needed to be r i
mean the best thing about it i thought
it had some good jokes in it i think the
best thing about it was like the
production design and the costume design
costumes were really good i mean i loved
that [ __ ]
oh now they bring that blade yeah first
two blades
third blade uh my friend was in it it
would suck the third blade
i don't even you know what i don't think
i saw if i did see it
then it didn't register with the third
one yeah the third one was a [ __ ]
abomination
it was i feel like i would have
remembered if it was an abomination
maybe i didn't see it
i think it might have went direct to dvd
um
what it was is the director was trying
to start his
his own series by kind of incorporating
some kind of
van helsing style vampire hunters in it
and so blade was kind of like a side gig
in that movie
and no it was that was terrible terrible
yeah one and two were strong they were
real good movies yeah time for another
one of those actually
um somebody up here just said uh
blumhouse is talking about redoing uh
blacula
which might be pretty good i don't know
one house is kind of hit or miss but
we'll see
depends on how they do it who's
directing it yeah let the right one in
is
is fantastic dermot brings up shadow of
the vampire which i feel like a lot of
people don't
maybe because it's not exactly a horror
movie
but i mean it kind of is and i just
rewatched that because i saw that in the
theater when it came out
and i really really loved it and then um
then i watched it again because i saw
that it was on 2b
or something like that i think i watched
it again like a month or two ago
and i loved it even more at that time
because i love silent movies i love all
the whole
[ __ ] aesthetic of that so you've
never seen shadow the vampire have you
no i don't think so that's willem dafoe
is in it and john malkovich is in it
it's basically about
the making of nosferatu so john
malkovich plays f w mernaud who was the
director
and willem dafoe plays max shrek the guy
who played nosferatu
or warlock and um but the catch of the
movie is that he is and
perhaps an actual vampire and he's like
and he starts like uh
killing members of the crew and fw
morneau is just kind of like well
we're cinema verite we're making a movie
here so it's like he's just kind of like
he kind of made a deal with mac shrek
that's like well you can eat some of the
minor members of the cats as long as
this is a good movie
it's just kind of that kind of thing
it's like a dark comedy also
isn't eddie is artisan i feel like he
played like the main
guy that was in wait you okay yeah
i was thinking klaus kinski's uh [ __ ]
nosferatu though
yeah that was a good character the movie
was kind of slow
but it had some really good ideas and
and it had a good
um tone to the movie it had an
ambiance to it but that was an
interesting take
on nosferatu because he wasn't cool at
all
not at all yeah not at all yeah he was
like yucky and creepy
nasty [ __ ] he was a plague and
when he showed up plague went with him
and he was kind of pitiful
yeah so i thought that was a good take i
thought it was too and that kind of goes
back a little bit to the book because
in the book he was a little bit of kind
of like a plague metaphor yeah
you know what i mean yeah he kind of
talked a little bit oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
she would die and stuff you know yeah
mango's talking about the 1979 version
with frank langella i like that one too
actually we watched that one uh
just a couple of weeks ago i think yeah
we just watched that one
yeah i always really like that one too
and it's funny because i remember when i
was a little kid i saw that
when i was maybe nine or ten years old
and that scene where they're down in the
catacombs or whatever like down in the
caves and uh van helsing find mina who
got turned into a vampire because they
switched the characters and it's the
whole thing
but when she kind of comes up to him and
they show her face and she's all like
kind of rotted with these weird like
eyes that are like lit up and [ __ ] like
that and that [ __ ] creeped me the
[ __ ] out
it scared me so much when i was a kid
that i had the novelization of that book
and i had to skip past that picture
because you know in the novelizations
they had like in the middle part they
had all the full color photos like from
the movie
and i always had to skip over that
because it weirded me out so much he's
bringing up natasha kenski and cat
people yeah man when i was a kid when
that movie came out they were playing it
on hbo
woman who could affect you when you're a
boy
well and if you were a girl too yeah
that woman would be a fan
i love i love that because uh i love
that movie good looking how could such a
weird looking dude come out with such a
[ __ ] sometimes
that happens sometimes that happens yeah
her and princess aura from [ __ ] um
the flash from flash gordon yeah what's
that what's that actress's name
italian yeah man in that red outfit
and coming onto the [ __ ]
flash and [ __ ] i was like yeah move
aside flash my my [ __ ] little skinny
ass
let me fly with the tip you know just
[ __ ] that wound was
[ __ ] gorgeous yeah
i think she was italian i can't remember
it i don't know jack or something i
thought i thought she might have been a
child you guys might remember that
something like that i can't remember
her accent alone and that big all that
long
black hair i love all the [ __ ] i but
that's another flash gordon is another
one that i love
the the set designs i love
costumes i was like if i could if i had
the money and i could design a house
that looked like that i would just i
would totally live in it that was when
dealer
when dino studios de la renta studios
that's when they had all this money they
were just spending
so much [ __ ] money on you know on on
these movies
that really they did okay but they
didn't make
huge returns that and it slowly went out
of business
uh but it was a very ambitious studio i
liked a lot of the deal i liked pretty
much
all the [ __ ] cool dino de laurentiis
well they all had something interesting
going on
even if they were failures they were
still
to look at flash gordon and they were
just great to look at
and i saw flash gordon in the theater
twice when it came out
loved it and then when it came out like
on hbo
on crt televisions that we had back then
it didn't it looked really bad
and a lot of people were kind of scoffed
at it but because i had seen it in the
theater i
i considered it to be like right there
with star wars and
you know empire strikes back i loved it
i was waiting for more of them they
never came though if you see that if
you've never seen that movie on blu-ray
on on a on a good hd television like you
have now
you will see how much attention to
detail they paid
it looks beautiful absolutely fantastic
beautiful movie
the costumes are perfect those are super
super expensive costumes they look
cheap on on crt tv well everything kind
of looked like ass
yeah it looked like ass but when you saw
seem on hd in hd they just look [ __ ]
great
the weave the materials and everything
they were real real expensive
and uh you couldn't look [ __ ] up and
be in a movie back then i mean everybody
had a certain look
you know [ __ ] max von sydow has
[ __ ]
knocked it out of the park he just did a
great he loved doing that role
and then the british guy who played
clydus i want that i want that costume
well we were talking going back years
ago we were going to be you were going
to be cletus and i was going to be
carla jenn mccullough um yeah and i was
just like
great man i was kind of looking into
because we're like man if we go to like
a horror convention this is like years
ago it's like we should totally do that
but then i was looking into how much it
would cost to do thousands
because i was like well i want it to
look just like that
and like i said you can't see how cool
those costumes look
on vhs but blu-ray you can see it
yeah you can't attempt those outfits
unless you go the high
high-quality route and all that [ __ ] was
handmade and very very expensive oh yeah
and general kala's outfit had those
little glass
rods what do you call those things yeah
they were also
they were all like lucite or something
like that they were kind of like
iridescent yeah and it was black gold
yeah they're not really beads though
they're rocks they were yeah they were
rods or they were or they were flat
they're
yeah or something you can get them still
yeah yeah um
but and it was all in in her collar it's
on this big you know and it's all
handmade
and they're wearing uh brass
helmets little brass helmets and hats
and
you know um um what's his name um
colitis mask is brass
yeah so or so you have to make that the
right way
and there was a guy that made just that
mask and he wanted about a grand for
that mask
yeah and that's how you have to go
man the rest of the costume is another
fifteen hundred two thousand dollars
to do that costume right with that
material and kyla's outfit was about
that too a couple grand
and you really wouldn't wear them that
often that's
yeah and it's that's the kind of thing i
even looked online i saw
a couple of women that had dressed like
carla
for conventions and some of the outfits
were like really good there weren't that
many because i guess it's
kind of an obscure character but that's
definitely one i mean i'm
i'm a person that if you're gonna go to
a convention or if you're going to a
halloween party or something like that
and you're gonna dress up as a character
it's gotta be right then it's gotta be
right you can't cheap out on it it can't
look like crap
um you know you can do your own take on
it if you want but i do kind of feel
like you have to make it look as
good as possible what was great about
that movie though
was the moral aspects of it
the humans the three humans that were
there were all kind of like had
they were kind of they were virtuous
all the aliens were corrupt the you know
the
the the mongos they were all corrupt
which i like that
that was [ __ ] kind of a cool touch
because
general kala and clydus they were part
of the secret police
and they were doing sexual tortures on
ming's daughter
bdsm and [ __ ] yeah and
clydus wanted her as as his wife and
ming was going to give her
to him and then and then
you know that colitis and general kala
were a thing so that was going to be a
threesome
all right sure and then
it's inferred that ming and his daughter
were getting it on
it was yeah it was rather yeah which is
interesting because if you see the
uh the original uh oh thank you thank
you very much no need for me to
what do you say shout out for life force
as one of my favorite underrated
practical movies with a stellar cast
i feel like that movie doesn't get
enough love yeah i mean life force it's
toby hooper you guys
yeah it held up well we saw space
vampires we saw it recently
yeah we reviewed it and actually i think
you can watch it i think it's on shutter
and it might be on tubey as well
species held up too that's another one
where you just got a naked beautiful
woman running around in it species that
one
yeah she wasn't a vampire she was an
alien he was alien yeah but both of
those movies
are trying to trying to get pregnant
yeah pregnant
[Laughter]
as he pranked pregnant what were you
saying about colin um
uh i don't remember no um oh i was gonna
say that
if you see the original flash gordon
serials
uh pre-haze code they they actually
implied like some pretty dirty [ __ ] in
that one
because you could get away with a lot
more back then before the haze code came
in so i feel like some of that like
weird incestuous stuff was implied back
then too
yeah you know what i mean but
you know they were they were aliens so i
guess they just got and they were royal
people so they just got down that way
so it was almost kind of like a rocky
horror picture moment where
they're saying oh these aliens are from
this planet where everybody just
yeah cross-dresses and sleeps with each
other and yeah and
it's so decadent you know what i mean i
feel like that's kind of a thing
she's like daddy give him to me
[Laughter]
surely you're what do you say you're
hungry your appetites are much too much
to taters
and daddy knows from firsthand
[Laughter]
he's like only if i can watch from from
the closet like i'm looking out for the
see
it's like [ __ ] filthy man yeah but
yeah it's a you know
one of these days if like i said if i
have money i still do want to do that
costume because that would be [ __ ]
man that would be so [ __ ] cool
yeah somebody mentioned that they just
released a new blu-ray of it
i have the older blu-ray and i actually
heard that the new blu-ray doesn't look
all that good that there's a couple
little glitches in it
in a place where the thing i don't think
the transfer is is really worth
getting the new version i was going to
get the new version but they wanted a 50
bucks for it
then there was a hundred dollar version
too you could get
but somebody reviewed it and said that
it's about like the old blu-ray yeah i
kind of feel like once you get to a
certain point it's gonna be like
diminishing returns and
i mean it's up to you if you want to pay
you know x amount of dollars for
whatever the upgrade is but
i don't know i feel like if i have a
thing that looks pretty damn good
and something comes out that looks
slightly better i don't know if i
necessarily want to spend money if it
looks like 100 times better than yeah
uh danny rolling ghostface was just
talking about the film uh ghost of war
yeah we actually we saw that
and i think we reviewed it yeah on a bad
news show that was like yeah that was
pretty good
and somebody said the old the old ones
from the 30s were good too yeah they are
they are good i've watched some of them
and you know
uh the delaurentis interpretation is
right there they're about the same
because if you go back to the 30s once
there's a bunch of uh
sexual references and refers to drugs
and everything
well it's weird yeah and also i feel
like there was less
of a stigma it's strange because
people tend to think you know you had
all these uh
all this [ __ ] back then like what was it
like [ __ ] reefer madness and all that
although that was a little bit later but
a lot
a lot of drugs were still legal back
then yeah you know what i mean
yeah like speed and [ __ ] like that like
various kind of yeah
and so was uh morphine you could get
morphy yeah so it's like they referred
to them they totally referred to them in
movies and actually if you see some old
silent movies like even comedies and
stuff like that
it'll just be really open like the guy
he's like the hero
he's like hey better go do my cocaine
and he's got like a little can of
cocaine on his desk and i'm gonna go
fight crime and he just goes and [ __ ]
sniffs it
and then runs out runs around yeah and
during the opening credits of the
original
um flash gordon they have a big forearm
satan statues dripping with
semi-nude women yeah dripping off of it
and
kind of like these orgasmic dances and
[ __ ]
they were scantily clad even by today's
stan standards
yeah do that i think was body stockings
but
some of that [ __ ] was damn near you know
what i mean you couldn't either you
couldn't have gotten away with that in
the 50s no way
no i mean 50s
by the time the 50s rolled around [ __ ]
man they were having there was a big
controversy where somebody wore a
[ __ ] one-piece bathing suit yeah that
was considered like scandalous which is
[ __ ] crazy
20s and 30s was wild it was it was wow
black people don't realize that [ __ ] but
that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
well i think that was one of the things
that made the hayes code come in and
there's
like we can't have all of this stuff
going on it's like oh my gosh it's so
it's so terrible and licentious yeah and
another thing is is that um
this is before the civil rights act and
everything and
there was there was uh iteration
relationships going on a lot of times
with the celebrities
um what was her name mae west over and
over again it was talked about
that her and her driver and her driver
was a big old
muscle-bound black dude everybody knew
that that was a couple
yeah you know and she would had jokes
about it
you know basically wants to go black
never go back type jokes she was doing
[ __ ] like that everybody knew
maywest was sorry mae west was this [ __ ]
yeah i would i'm i'm fascinated by all
that
old hollywood stuff yeah old hollywood
actually was kind of cool
but they were they were uh they really
were kind of like on the cutting edge
um yeah they were and they had to stop
it that's why they did all this [ __ ]
yeah because you could get away with a
lot of [ __ ] well why do
like i said why do you think they crack
down the [ __ ] because you had the whole
thing about you know the fatty arbuckle
uh thing and uh you know there were a
couple other murders like uh
what's that dude's name that got shot in
the back uh desmond william desmond
taylor
yeah and um you know there's a lot of
them were on drugs and [ __ ] like that
so i i kind of feel like that was
you know everybody was clutching their
pearls about and louise brooks
just openly talk about going to lesbian
clubs in berlin
yeah a lot a lot of nude selfies real
artistic
nude subjects i liked louise brooks
though she was cute yes she was she was
super funny she was kidding she was
doing [ __ ] when she was a teenager
um so it's 20s and 30s was
actually i guess you could say that was
kind of a time of sexual revolution
probably better than the 60s you know
because they were doing cool [ __ ] and
they looked a lot better
you know the average [ __ ] hippie
during the 60s look at that [ __ ] all
that [ __ ]
they were very stylish you know it's
just that i feel like you couldn't talk
about it openly
but everybody on the other hand
everybody yeah it all had to be like and
you ended whatever
you because um they had
i've seen some of those shows on youtube
because they'll play them
where they had a weird show where
everybody's in all these celebrities are
in a nightclub and it goes from one
celebrity table to the next and they do
a little routine and there's a lot of
jokes
and you have to be an adult to really
kind of understand the jokes i don't
know what kind of show it was it's like
a variety
shows that they would make and then
there would be a dance number
and there were girls making references
open references to the casting couch
yeah
all kinds of [ __ ] so yeah they knew they
were they were
you know well like i said they were not
brutish they knew what was going on
they were not prudish they knew what was
going on big time yep
kevin smith presumably not that kevin
smith
but he says you guys don't know me but
you have one of the best channels
no thank you very much kevin smith thank
you very much you could very well be
that kevin smith i'm not really sure
loved tusk
[Laughter]
just saying yeah because no need for
major said wow kevin smith follows 13
o'clock
yeah yeah buster crab flash gordon i
feel like we didn't bust her crab he did
like a lot of um
please correct me if i'm wrong but
didn't he do like a lot of diving stuff
because he was i feel like he was uh
didn't he play tarzan am i getting that
wrong i don't know
somebody's mentioned that drake driggers
said that that company's
shout and scream factory is notorious
for a seat for quality control issues he
had to get three replaced discs on
friday
the 13th box set i didn't know i was uh
was the flash gordon one was that um
it might have been shout factory because
i have some shout factory stuff but it's
all been good
yeah we i've had good luck with them
because they they released a lot of uh
mystery science theater
yeah box sets and i have pretty much all
of those and i don't think i've ever
have had any issues with those and i've
watched them all
so you know yeah oh what oh
i wanted to give another um i wanted to
give another uh
reminder to people who are big mst nerds
like i am
to go over to their kickstarter and give
them some monies
so they can do like i said they're
building they got enough money
to what they call build the gizmoplex
which i guess
it's going to be essentially like a
virtual online theater
deliveries here okay because sometimes
they don't ring the bell sometimes they
just leave it and [ __ ] off
they usually don't ring the bell
actually um but yeah so
they're building like um an online
theater that they're gonna have events
like virtual events
and um they also got to their i think
their third goal which i think was 4.4
million i think they just got to that
so and now it's gonna have an app that
you can um
that'll you know you can do it on your
phone or whatever and um
so they're gonna start doing like
i don't know they're gonna just start
doing all these live events i can't
remember how many episodes they're up to
now but i think they have enough money
to do
nine new episodes if i'm not mistaken um
so that's going to be really cool and
they have like a bunch of like really
cool rewards and [ __ ]
they hadn't brought anything no not yet
but i had to let beige out
bases keep that door open and then wait
keep the door open and then she gets the
door and slows down
slows down he's kind of an [ __ ] like
those [ __ ] get on the goddamn
crosswalk and they'll go fast until they
get in front of your car and then they
start slowing down and bringing cars
just to be spiteful
i kind of feel like beijing does it just
to be spiteful because that's kind of
what she's like
oh you guys speaking of cats um you
remember i was talking about past kitty
that
little that little dude cat that i see
on the trail where i walk this morning
we found out what his name was his name
is mr maguire yes
[Laughter]
when they told me i laughed so hard
because i'm like yeah that's that he
looks like a mr mcguire i was thinking
because i was looking at his face one
day and being like i gotta call you
something other than path kitty it's
like and i was like you could look
he looks kind of distinguished and
serious i said you look like a mr
i said you look like mr theodore that's
what i thought and you said he looked
like
a conrad yeah i thought his name was
conrad
it's like he looks like a conrad yeah
and i was like yeah he kind of looks
like a conrad too
but mr mcguire is also good so so now i
can call him by his name but we know
where he lives you know they got money
so you know i was thinking one of those
looking rich ass yuppy names you know
what i mean
like his name is his first name is kent
or his first name is conrad
man when i was a kid all these [ __ ]
rich kids that i [ __ ] knew man
they would give this their yuppie-ass
parents
would give them these crazy names and
they were gonna go get another uh
if you guys can still hear us we're
having technical issues
so we might have to start another one
i'm not really sure i'm gonna give it a
couple minutes
and see it looks like the chat's still
going so maybe you can still hear
us but i might have to start a new
stream
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
did it come back and
it does not well maybe
maybe i keep looking over at his uh [ __ ]
come on